ich würde gerne heute abend mit ihnen
besprechen dass ich persönlich finde
dass wir frauen nach wie vor lichtjahre
davon entfernt sind gleich fokussiert
unsere beruflichen ziele verfolgen zu
können wie die herren der schöpfung ich
habe das gefühl man muss sich
entscheiden zwischen vollblut mama und
karriere weit ich wusste gar nicht wo
ich mich persönlich einordnen sollte da
ich meinen job unheimlich liebe meine
tochter natürlich über alle maßen noch
viel mehr trotzdem könnte ich mir nicht
vorstellen vollzeit zu hause zu sein und
auch wenn es ist richtig fies trinke ich
bin teilweise nach zwei tagen zu hause
rund um die uhr kinderbetreuung an so
einem wochenende allein fertiger als
wenn ich zwei shootings und zwei
kontinenten habe und einfach
zwischendurch meine zeit für mich im
flugzeug ein bisschen meine musik hören
kann meine gedanken bei nicht
erwachsenen austauschen ich komme nach
hause und bin einfach gefühlt eine
bessere mama habe neuen impuls für meine
ehe für mein kind und fühle mich in
dieser rolle wirklich unglaublich wohl
muss mir allerdings mit 32 jetzt auch
ganz oft anhören bleibt endlich das
zweite kind und das kann ich mir aktuell
beruflich nicht leisten ich bin
selbstständig ich leite eine firma ich
gehe zwei verschiedenen berufen nach in
der selbständigkeit momentan hat ein
zweites kind keinen platz selbst meine
gynäkologen wie ich mich an und sagt
frau gäbe die biologische uhr tickt das
wissen sie haben nicht mehr die
schnellen wie eine 20-jährige recht und
es finde ich unglaublich dieser trug dem
ich mich auf einmal ausgesetzt fühlen
muss ich weiß nicht ob das alles so
richtig ist und mein mann stolperte auf
dem kaiserschnitt schreibt in seinen
anzug und selbst einem meeting und sein
leben geht nahtlos weiter schon da für
mich sind wir irgendwie halten also da
kann ich ihnen sagen als vierfache ford
oder auch jeden tag zu sagen die
vereinbarkeit zwischen seinem
privatleben als vor ort und seinem
geschäftsleben nicht auf die reihe
kriegt entspannen sie sich entspannen
sie sich das ist halt eine wie soll ich
sagen das ist etwas das los das kreuz
der frauen auf eine art dass ich meine
ganz wichtig mütter das ist etwas extrem
wichtig ist ich meine man muss auch
mütter sind dafür die entwicklung der
kinder und so was sehr wichtig ist aber
gleichzeitig gibt es viele andere
möglichkeiten auch noch und mein playboy
ist einfach das macht euch doch keinen
zu großen stress erstens zweitens wie
man sich organisiert muss man natürlich
in der familie in schaan jede familie
die sie ansprechen es gibt andere
optionen nanny oder ein mann
das ist der entscheidende punkt ist
zwingt sie oder niemand den unattraktiv
mann zu heiraten sie können jetzt an dem
baum aussuchen der ihrem lebensentwurf
und ihren familien verständnis
entspricht und ich glaube dass doch noch
interessant wir erleben jetzt eine neue
sexuelle revolution es ist nämlich die
neue sogenannte
reproduktionsmedizin die ja auch eine
gewisse
befreiung auch bringt vielleicht eine
flexibilität aber am ende des tages habe
ich komme nicht wegleugnen auch wenn man
uns einredet dass es keine fixen
geschlechter mehr gibt und ich morgen
zum standesamt gehen kann und mich zum
frau erklären kann wenn ich mir danach
ist frauen zahlen einen höheren preis
weil für karriere weil die biologische
uhr tickt aber ich kann sagen sagen sie
ist mit fassung und suchen sie einen
mann der einfach sie unterstützt fertig
das macht man so gut er kann wirklich an
macht das fabelhaft aber ich würde mich
auch niemals ich würde ihn niemals darum
bitten mehr zu hause zu bleiben er hat
einen managerjob er hat eine 70 stunden
woche er hat seine beruflichen
verpflichtungen die habe ich natürlich
allerdings auch und nach wie vor haben
wir trotzdem öfter mal die diskussion
weil gefühlt auch wenn ich jetzt aus dem
nähkästchen plaudern ist ganz oft so
dass er sagt ich kann alles hin
wortwörtlich ich muss leider eine woche
in die usa ist jetzt so ich glaube ich
eine lösung ich hab mir nur noch ein
bewerbe mich bewerbe aber nein das ist
zu spät ob es fehler werden
den kindern vorlesen das würde ich weiß
ich hab ich muss sagen gleich wie es
vielleicht bin ich ein richtiger zizmann
ich weiß wie das gibt nicht liebe kinder
und ich muss sagen ich finde kinder viel
interessanter als die meisten
erwachsenen die haben sich unterhaltung
also ich wäre es gehe jetzt geliebt
lehrer zu werden ich habe ab einem
gewissen alter fangen kinder an zu
nerven sie wenn sie so 17 18 fangen sie
an zu nerven aber junge kinder die sich
die die sich noch gern gehirn war noch
formen kann die große augen machen wir
werden erst verließ ich beneide euch
mütter im grunde dafür dass sie dieses
dass ihr das privileg gehabt diese
kinder zu lange in eurem eigenen bruder
eurem herzen tragen zu können und ich
was ich an unserer gesellschaft wirklich
wirklich wirklich beweise ist dass das
fast schon zum von der gesellschaft zum
manko erklärt werden dass die frau zu
einem sessel
90 mm interview mit n m mit einer
familienpolitischen der spd gehört hat
die armen frauen die müssen ja kinder
bekommen mein gott wie beneide ich
wollte sicher schön ist doch so langsam
dass vor ihm ein dass sie zum marko ja
genau dann wenn man dann hause bleiben
möchte das wird wieder schwächer da gab
und man traut sich kaum zu sagen ich bin
hausfrauen ich sie wirklich meinen hut
vor mamas frau mehrfach massiv zu hause
sondern ihre kinder ziehen und ich muss
auch sagen für mich gibt es nichts
größeres meine tochter ist 4 und wie du
gerade sagt dass diese strahlenden
kleinen kinderaugen jeden tag kommt
neues das aber gleichzeitig dass andere
promi vollversorgung wenn ich daran
denke meine als meiner lieblings frauen
ist es hannah arendt übrigens
kettenraucherin johanna die hannah
arendt hat dieses großartigen ukraine
weiter aktiver ich verstehe natürlich
auch frauen die sagen sie möchten jetzt
hast du so schön beschrieben ich möchte
auch mal mit und erwachsenen seien ich
möchte bezahlt werden für etwas was ich
leiste und der name ich da am ende des
tages nach hause kommen das ist dieses
gefühl des handwerkers frauen auch schon
habt dann ein stuhl in der hatte nicht
selber gebaut das ist gar nicht so ganz
nicht
verfolgt gar nicht da ganz wichtig war
in einem statement du hast ja auch das
zweite kind angesprochen das ja sagst du
kriegst du super und krieg ich wirklich
leben unter herre die frage ist hast du
denn auch jobs verloren als du dein kind
bekommen hat es sie jetzt sagt ich habe
schon angst und zweites zu bekommen lena
wir haben uns vor darüber unterhalten
ich habe meine tochter sozusagen auf dem
höhepunkt meiner karriere bekommen ich
habe zwei bundesliga sendungen moderiert
ein in england eine in deutschland das
war der traum meiner meiner ganzen
meines ganzen lebens ich wollte immer
eine eigene 20.15 sendung haben und in
der sport oder in der politik moderat zu
landen das habe ich geschafft und dann
kam mein kind und es ist wirkliches
wunder schönste auf der ganzen welt aber
naiv wie man dann natürlich so an die
sache herangeht denkt man ok dann
bekomme ich mein baby ich möchte es aber
auch richtig machen ich möchte sie
stellen also nehme ich die kleine maus
einfach mit die warte dann schließlich
im maxi-cosi während mama von eine live
kamera sitzt aber in der realität ist
alles anders und sobald du dieses mama
herz in die erschlagen hast du achtest
du nicht mehr was meine persönlichen
beruflichen ziele und was das beste für
mich und meinen werdegang im hier und
jetzt da denkst du dieses kleine
lebewesen braucht routine braucht sein
zuhause braucht ein kinderbettchen in
denen schläft und garantiert nicht ein
flugzeug drei tage die woche also habe
ich mich hinten angestellt und es hat
mich und ich bin sehr tüchtig und ich
hab noch fünf wochen der geburt wieder
gearbeitet 3 gekostet bis ich genau da
war wie ich vorher aufgehört habe wenn
ich überhaupt in der moderation habe ich
noch nicht ganz geschafft im modeln
spielend leicht ja aber ich habe
wirklich hart dafür arbeiten müssen und
ja manche mama schaffen es gar nicht
mehr weil es auch wirklich schwierig ist
zu vereinbaren und in allen berufen ist
nicht unbedingt möglich verdoppeln
möchte sich zu ich habe vor 11 13 11 bis
13 jahren drei kinder fast auf einmal
bekommen und ich weiß wie das ist wenn
man plötzlich von mama sein soll und
wenn man weiter arbeiten will aber ich
habe das problem was wir haben ist dass
wir immer diskutieren das dass das thema
der frauen ist weil meine erfahrung ist
das ganze ding klappt nur dann wenn der
man sich auch entscheidet genauso
zuhause mit anzupacken genauso beruflich
auch ein bisschen zurückzutreten es ist
ja nur eine gewisse zeit man kann dann
wieder gas geben und meine erfahrung ist
auch es ist zwar viel was man dann ja
geld aber wenn man das zusammen als team
macht und beide mithelfen dann geht es
aber es erfordert auch den arbeitgeber
der da ein bisschen rücksicht nehmen
sollten sagte hanna die sich für ihre
karriere entscheiden die verpassen auch
ganz viel und ich glaube als ganze
gesellschaft ja ich meine mädels daten
gesellschaft ist das total wichtig dass
wir verstehen kinder sind keine
frauensache wir sind wir genauso klug
wir müssen genau so ging das auch noch
genau es gibt mir nach und vaterlose
gesellschaft wir haben eine www wachsen
eigentlich und es gibt zahlreiche narben
einer vaterlosen gesellschaft auch wir
sind die verlierer wir sind völlig
überfordert der ganzen situation und und
jonglieren jonglieren und machen und tun
und organisieren wir müssen aber auch
von unserem perfektionismus ablassen das
heißt wenn mein mann zu hause das macht
ja und mir soll die hand abfallen wenn
ich jetzt lüge dann macht er das auf
seine art ja und das muss sich fressen
die kröten das heißt ich komme nicht
nach hause und denke wo ok oder was auch
immer
praktiker als praktizierende fordere
muss jedoch auch eine lanze für den
filter sparte brechen indem sie ich
meine die männer stehen ja auch unter
einem gewissen stress denn wir wissen
auch oder wenn wir uns von den
strahlenden masters of the universe die
wir uns einbilden zu sein wird sich zum
hausmann wandeln wir haben das bei brad
pitt gesehen der ist ja von angelina
jolie geradezu zu einem ist ihr herab
provoziert domestiziert worden und hat
uns eine attraktivität einfach hat es
muss unterscheiden punkt machen also dem
man steht ja auch unter einem
erwartungsdruck der frau dass er dort
performance muss er muss der superstar
seine die frau gibt ihnen das gefühl
mein plädoyer in all diesen
verstrickungen das muss man vorher
besprechen ich habe meiner frau gesagt
ich hatte schon eine firma eine
unternehmen aber hoch verschuldete firma
gekauft und ich habe mir eine frage
gesagt du musst einfach etwas wissen du
heiratest einem verheirateten mann ich
muss diese firma durchbringt wenn du das
nicht willst wenn du das nicht
tolerieren ist wenn du einen
millionenerben heiraten willst um 15
prozent arbeiter muskat ferien auf ich
bring dir einfach dafür dass muss man am
anfang besprechen was mich ärgert ist
dass wir vorhin beim rauchen gesprochen
haben dass auch hier immer nach dem
staat gerufen dem start muss der staat
muss und ich sage dann müssen doch auch
die eheleute am anfang muss man das ganz
praktisch besprechen sagen du wie siehst
du das kannst du mal reduzieren geht das
bist du in der lage und das muss man
vorher machen und viele besprechen das
nicht und dann hat man den großen salat
aber meist ordentlich anderen ändern
sobald die situation ist wie sie ist ja
ich habe gerade im freundeskreis ein
pärchen ich habe gerade mit ihm darüber
gesprochen die waren fabelhaft wir haben
alle zu ihm hoch geschaut der mann hat
pariert er war fabelhaft erwartet wie
also noch mal vorher schon wurde
mittlerweile hat sich die situation
verändert die haben anstatt der wechsel
hingelegt er arbeitet viel mehr sie
sitzt mit mittlerweile zwei kinder nach
hause aus der femme fatale ist eine
richtige hausfrau geworden ihre ehe
es ist traurig dass kann auszusprechen
man sieht wie sie langsam einfach zu
bröckeln beginnen das war vorher eine
ganz fleißige geschäftsfrau mit eigenen
imprivata verlauf bei den beiden ich
finde diese höhere ebene russin du grad
angestiegen was aber bewerbung
gesprochen und es war ihr plan und
mittlerweile merck sowie einfach beide
in ihren rollen ja gar nicht so
glücklich sind sie gesagt ich
glaube für mich eines der sätze
kinder sind keine traum sache und ich
bin der kinder brauchen brauchen den
vater sowohl die töchter brauchen den
vater und natürlich kennen diese
situation wie viele viele freunde ich
glaube es auch für ein mann nicht gesund
110 einen job zu geben und
und ich muss rose widersprach es ist
nämlich doch eine sache des staates wir
brauchen die möglichkeit eine super
kinderbetreuung da geht es um nach
alexander glück haben diese kinder die
sich das ist also das ist ja
das hat gesagt hat in einem brief an
karl marx wir müssen die kinder so früh
wie möglich darum werden sobald sie den
mütterlichen fürsorge nicht mehr
bedürfen wörtlich autorität der familie
ziehen und in erziehungsanstalten steckt
mit einer forderung wie möglich die
kleinsten kinder schon den in detroit
frankreich ganz gut ja ja wir müssen
also leute gucken